[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
بدايه هشه للهدنه في السودان اطلاق نار
وتحليق للطائرات في الخرطوم واشتباكات في
ام درمان
اوكرانيا تؤكد انها لا تزال تسيطر على
مناطق في بخموت وتحذر من نقص الذخيره لبدء
الهجوم المضاد
بعد ضمان دعم اوغان اردوغان ينفي اي
مساومه مع المرشح المنسحب وكليجدار اوغلو
يؤكد لن تخدعوا الشعب
ومحكمه في اسلام اباد تمدد كفاله عمران
خان ضد الاعتقال في قضايا مكافحه ارهاب
وفساد
اهلا بكم نبدا من السودان يبدو انها بدايه
هشه للهدنه بعد ساعات على دخولها حيز
التنفيذ رغم انها الهدنه الاولى التي يجري
الاتفاق عليها رسميا بعد اجراء مفاوضات
بين طرفي النزاع شهد اتفاق وقف اطلاق
النار خروقات من ساحات العاصمه الخرطوم
وافاد شهود عيان بتحليق مقاتلات في سماء
المدينه واستمرار المواجهات في بعض
المناطق لا سيما مع سماع ذوي قصف في الشرق
لم يختلف الحال كثيرا لدى سكان ام درمان
وبحري لانهم ذكروا ان اصوات النيران
المستمره بدلت حاله الهدوء النسبي وتحدثت
وسائل اعلام عن سماع اصوات مواجهات وغارات
جويه جنوب العاصمه وفي الضواحي الشماليه
الشرقيه بالاضافه الى وقوع اشتباكات في
شارع الغابه وسط الخرطوم ورغم ان القتال
لم يهدا نهائيا بين الطرفين الا ان
الاتفاق جدد الامال في توقف الحرب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وعلى وقع المعارك رغم سريان الهدنه حذرت
الامم المتحده على لسان مبعوثها الى
السودان
حضرت مما وصفته بتحول الصراع الذي يشهده
هذا البلد منذ اكثر من شهر الى نزاع عرقي
متنامن داعيه طرفي القتال الى الالتزام
باحدث اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار والذي ابرم
بينهما
معنى من بورتسودان مراسل العربيه نزار
بقداوي ومن اقليم دار فوره صحفي صالح ابو
علامه اهلا بكما جميعا ابدا مع نزار كيف
هو الوضع على الارض مع سريان هذه الهدنه
هل ما زالت الخروقات قائمه واي المناطق
تقوم فيها هذه الخروقات طيب اذا يبدو ان
نزار ليس معنا بعد ولكن انتقل الى الصحفي
صالح ابو علامه صالح يعني انقل لنا الصوره
لديك ما الذي يحدث من خروقات بعد بدا هذه
الهدنه
نعم ليله البارحه طوال الليل هنالك اصوات
رصاص تسمع في ولايه جنوب دارفور مدينه
نيالا في اتجاهات مختلفه داخل الاحياء
بمدينه نيالا وهنالك ايضا انتشار واسع
لقوات الدعم السريع هنالك ايضا انتشار
للجيش داخل سوق مدينه نيالا وفي انحاء
متفرقه من المدينه المعارك التي شهدتها
مدينه نيالا خلال الايام الماضيه والذي
انتهت يوم الاحد رفعت من حده التوتر بين
الجيش والدعم السريع هنالك قناصه منتشرين
في اماكن مختلفه بسوق المدينه وفي
البنايات العاليه
بمدينه نيالا الوضع داخل السوق وداخل
الاحياء لا يمكن
ابدا نسبه لعمليات الانفلات الكبيره التي
تمت فيها الطرقات وعمليات السلب والنهب
التي طالت الاحياء واطاله المحلات
التجاريه واطالت ايضا بعض المصارف
والاسواق بجنوب دارفور هذه الهدنه لم تحسن
ابدا
طيب صالح لا اسمعك ولكن كنت تقول بان هذه
الهدنه ربما لم تحسن الوضع من باب النهب
وما يقوم به من خروقات انتقل الى نزار
نزار انت تنضم الينا من بورتسودان ولكن ما
الانباء الوارده لديك من الخرطوم والمناطق
التي تشهد خروقات للهدنه حتى الان
[موسيقى]
هي مدينه بورسودان بولايه
البقيه السودان الكره الان يتابع مواطنون
ومراقبون ومنظمات دوليه وسفارات وحكومه
حتى الوزراء الذين وصلوا خلال الايام
الماضيه الى مدينه بورسودان يراقبون عن
كثب عبر الوسائط وعبر المعلومات
تداعيات ومسارات واشارات هذه الهدنه التي
بدات خلال التعاطي الماضيه
المعلومات تتحدث كما ذكر الزملاء عن
اخبار هنا وهنالك في بعض المناطق في اطراف
الخرطوم او في عدد من مناطق دارفور او
خارج العاصمه لكن ما يهم المواطن هنا في
ولايه البحر الاحمر التي تشهد استقرارا
امنيا وخدميا
واستقرار مجتمعي على صعيد المواطنين على
صعيد البعثات التي وصلت الى شرق السودان
وحتى على صعيد الالاف من طالبي الاجلاء
والمغادره الذين وصلوا الى ولايه البحر
الاحمر هم ايضا يراقبون وتداعيات هذه
الهدنه لانها ستنعكس بصوره او باخرى على
مسار رحلتهم ومسار المساعدات التي وصلت
الان الى ولايه البحر الاحمر وتقدر باكثر
من 900
طوما من المساعدات الغذائيه وتنتظر ايضا
ولايه البحر الاحمر خلال الايام الماضيه
ولكن ماذا عن حاله النزوح هل من اي نزوح
متصاعد ربما منذ بدايه ساعات الهدنه
الاولى سريعا لو سمحت نزار
[موسيقى]
ونحو التهدئه ونحو الاستقرار نتوقع بحسب
المعلومات ان تصل اعداد اضافيه من الاسر
ومن العائلات من ولايه الجزيره ومن مدينه
الشندي ومن العاصمه
القران مدينه بورسودان كل هذا
رهن فقط كيف ستنظر ساعات المقبله من مسار
الهدنه هل ستلتزم الاطراف بوقف اطلاق
النار ام ان الامور ستمضي كما مضى عليك
خلال اليوم
انتقل الى الصحفي صالح ابو علامه صالح هل
رصدتم اي دور للفرق الرقابيه التي يعني من
المفترض انها تتواجد هناك لمراقبه الهدنه
وعدم حدوث اي خروقات
نعم حتى الان
الحركه هي صعبه جدا في مدينه نيالا وفي
الاحياء بمدينه نيالا لا يمكن لاحد ابدا
ان يتحرك في الاماكن التي دارت فيها
الاشتباكات او الدخول بين الطرفين في
الجنوب دارفور هنالك انتشار كبير للسلاح
هنالك عمليات التفلت هناك عمليات قصف
عشوائي ايضا حتى الان هنالك جثث لم ترفع
بمدينه نيالا لكن اذا تحسن الوضع ربما
يعني المبادرات الرسميه والمراقبين
يتحركون داخل
الاسواق وفي اماكن متعدده ايضا ليله
البارحه تحدث قائد قوات الدعم السريع بان
الدعم السريع سيعمل على قبض المتفلتين
ويعمل على قبض المقربين داخل المدن حتى
الان هذه الخطوه ايضا لم تبدا ولكن اذا ما
بدات ربما تحسن من الوضع الامني قليلا
خاصه ان هنالك انتشار كبير في عمليات
التخريب والتفلت
تساؤل ما سبب هذا الانفلات ومن هم
المتسببون به رغم سريان الهدنه شكرا لكما
من بورت سودان مراسل العربيه نزار بقداوي
ومن اقليم دارفور الصحفي صالح ابو علامه
حرب السودان مشاهدينا شردت اكثر من مليون
نازح ولاجئ اكثر من 250 الف منهم غادروا
السودان وذلك بحسب تقديرات مفوضيه الامم
المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين ومنذ اكثر من شهر
بلغ عدد الفارينه الى تشاد ووحدها نحو 90
الف شخص 90% منهم من النساء والاطفال وتم
ايواء غالبيتهم في مخيمات مؤقته شرق
البلاد قرب حدود السودان وقد حذرت الامم
المتحده من ارتفاع اعداد النازحين جراء
اعمال العنف ما يشكل صعوبه في توفير
المساعدات والماوى لهم
[موسيقى]
نشرتنا مستمره ونتابع فيها
واشنطن تجزم بان فاجنر الروسيه تسعى
لتمرير اسلحه من مالي
[موسيقى]
احييكم من جديد الى الصراع الروسي
الاوكراني حيث دعا حاكم بلغراد الروسيه
المتاخمه لاوكرانيا دعا السكان لمغادره
المقاطعه لملاحقه من وصفهم بمجموعات
تخريبيه واعلن حاكم بلغراد عن هجمات
بطائرات مسيره تستهدف مسلحين توغلوا الى
المقاطعه وقال ان عمليه مكافحه الارهاب
تتواصل في المنطقه مؤكدا ان وزاره الدفاع
ووكالات انفاذ القانون تعمل على تطهيرها
بحسب قوله
اوكرانيا افاد مراسل العربيه بان الجيش
الاوكراني استهدف المدينه وضواحيها
بثمانيه صاروخا وقذيفه مدفعيه اسفرت عن
مقتل شخص واصابه اثنين بجروح كما ادى
القصف الى تضرر تسعه ابنيه سكنيه ومرفقين
ياتي ذلك فيما اعلن حاكم مقاطعه كورسك
الروسيه ان القريه الحدوديه في المقاطعات
عرضت لانقطاع التيار الكهربائي بسبب قصف
الجيش الاوكراني اما في بخموت فقد اكدت
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان قواتها لا
تزال تسيطر على مواقع في جنوب غرب المدينه
وقالت نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني وتيره
القتال داخل باق موت انخفضت بشكل كبير
بينما تقوم القوات الروسيه بتمشيط المناطق
التي سيطرت عليها
من دنيتك مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر اهلا
بك معنا رائد اذا يعني من اردنا ان نتحدث
عن بخموت ما زالت هناك معارك قائمه رغم
انخفاضها بحسب المسؤوله الاوكرانيه كيف هي
مجريات المعارك هناك في بخموت وهل بالفعل
تقوم القوات الروسيه بتمشيط تلك المنطقه
والمناطق المجاوره لها
صباح الخير فاطمه بالفعل مدينه بخموت حتى
الان تشهد عمليات عسكريه لكنها ليس في
داخل المدينه هي على الاجنحه وعلى المنطقه
الغربيه وجدير بالذكر ان الذي يحارب او
يدافع عن المدينه بعد اعلان السيطره
الكامله من قبل قوات فاجنر هو الجيش
الروسي الجيش الروسي عاد وسيطره على اجنحه
المدينه وخاصه جناح الجنوبي الذي يشهد
حشودات كبيره للقوات الاوكرانيه ومحاولات
للعوده والدخول في العمق في مدينه باقمت
لكن هناك مصادر عسكريه تؤكد بان جيش
الروسي ينحي مئات المقاتلين الاوكرانيين
ويدمر عشرات الاليات خلال اليومين
الماضيين كما ان المدينه تشهد عمليات
تنظيف وتمشيط من مخلفات الحرب من الالغام
التي تركها الجيش الاوكراني خلفه بالفعل
قبل ان انتقل الى كاتيا من موسكو
بالفعل ابديفكا تشهد معارك ضاريه ومحاولات
من الجيش الروسي لتوسيع الطوق لان القوات
الروسيه تحاول تطويق المقاتلين المتحصنين
داخل مدينه افديكا وهناك عمليات مرتده وسط
حشود اوكرانيه كبيره معارك ضاريه في محور
يعتبر الاكثر سخونه في الايام الماضيه
ابقى معي رائد سانتقل الى موسكو ومراسلتنا
من هناك كاتيا طعمه كاتيا يعني اقتحامات
لبلغراد واتهامات روسيه بانها قوات
اوكرانيه رغم ان في الاوكراني ملء لديك
حول هذه الاقتحامات ما الذي يحدث في
بلغراد تحديدا
مرحبا فاطمه بالفعل يوم امس اقتحمت مجموعه
تخريبيه اوكرانيه كما تحدثت السلطات هناك
في المدينه الحدود ودخلت الاراضي وتسللت
الى الاراضي الروسيه هي مجموعه تقريبيه
اوكرانيه كما اكدت مرارا السلطات الروسيه
كانت قد تحدثت عن وجود فيديو ايضا يثبت
دخول هذه او تسلل هذه المجموعه هبه عباره
عن مجموعه من
الرجال الاوكرانيين الذين كانوا في فوز
تحمل اشارات وشارات صفراء وكانوا على
مدرعات امريكيه من نوع هامبي كما تحدثت
السلطات هناك وكان طبعا كانت المنطقه اللي
هي منطقه
هي التي شهدت
يوم امس معارك بين السلطات المحليه وطبعا
هي وزاره الدفاع التي تقوم بتصفيه هؤلاء
الذين تسللوا الى المنطقه طبعا نتيجه
اطلاقهم للنار ادت الى اولا تخريب لبعض
المباني السكنيه بالاضافه الى سقوط جرحى
الى نحو ثمانيه اشخاص سقط جرحى من سكان
المدينه المحليين وتم اخلاء المنطقه طبعا
كما تحدث رئيس
اليوم كان قد نبه السكان من عدم العوده
الان الى منازلهم بسبب خطوره البوقف هناك
كان طبعا هناك ايضا اليوم استمرارا
للهجومات الاوكرانيه هناك كان هجوم
اوكرانيا جديد عبر المسيرات باستخدام
المسيرات والتي تم قصفها طبعا من قبل
انظمه الدفاع الروسيه كما تحدث المتحدث
الرسمي باسم الكرب يوم امس انها الرئيس
الروسي على الصراع كامل بالوضع هناك في
منطقه وهي منطقه حدوديه تبعد 40 نحو 40
كيلومتر عن اوكرانيا هي دائما تشهد طبعا
هي منطقه ساخنه دائما تشهد منذ بدايه
العمليه العسكريه تشهد
اما هجوم من الطرف الاوكر اني
عمليه تسلل او بمثيرات ويتم صدها دائما
بانظمه الدفاع الجويه الروسيه كما تحدث
ايضا الدفاع الروسيه ان هناك نظام محاربه
الارهاب تم فرضه في المدينه للقضاء على
هذه المجموعه التخريبيه في التي تسللت يوم
امس فاطمه شكرا لك من موسكو مراسله
العربيه
رائد الاغبر
اعلن رئيس الاستخبارات العسكريه في وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تمتلك الحد الادنى من الاسلحه اللازمه
لشني هجوم مضاد لكنه لفتا الى ان الهجوم
سيكون في المستقبل القريب والعاجل واشتكى
خلال مقابله مع قناه ان اتش كي اليابانيه
من ان بحاجه الى مزيد من الاسلحه وتحديدا
المقاتلات هذه الشكوى الاوكرانيه مشاهدينا
من نقص الذخيره تاتي قبل ساعات من
اجتماعات او اجتماعات نعم وزراء الدفاع
لدول الاتحاد الاوروبي في بروكسل لبحثي
خطه التنفيذ للمتعلقه بالدعم العسكري
لاوكرانيا ومن المقرر ان يقدم الاتحاد
تمويلات بقيمه مليار يورو لتغطيه نفقات
تزويد اوكرانيا بمليون قذيفه هذا العام
عدا عن تمويل جزء من فواتير اعاده تشكيل
المخزون الاوروبي وحظ بقيه الاعضاء على
المساهمه فالدرمارك مثلا وهولندا اعلنتا
بالفعل عن الاستعداد لتزويد اوكرانيا
اما بلجيكا فما زالت متردده ما يعني ان
مساله امدادها بالمقاتلات حسمت تقريبا
وسيجري التركيز في المرحله المقبله على
تدريب الطيارين العمليه التي تتطلب اربعه
اشهر على الاقل وحول هذا التدريب تحديدا
اكد مفوض الشؤون الخارجيه للاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل اكد ان دولا اوروبيه
عده بدات بتدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين
بالفعل على مقاتله اف 16 ومنها بولندا
واشار الى ان اوروبا قدمت عشره مليارات
يورو حتى الان دعما عسكريا لاوكرانيا
واعلن ايضا وزير الدفاع الالماني بورس
بورس بيوتروي بيتريوس برلين تدرس دعما
تحالف يهدف لتزويد اوكرانيا بمقاتلات لكن
ستكون مساهمه بسيطه لان المانيا نفسها لا
تمتلك هذه المقاتلات ومن جانبها اعترضت
المجر على اتفاق تمويل المساعدات العسكريه
الى اوكرانيا معتبره ان الدول الاوروبيه
التي ترسل اسلحه الى اوكرانيا تخاطر
بامنها وتقلل من مخزونها الاستراتيجي حيث
شدد وزير الدفاع المجري كريستوف سالاي على
ان المجر ركزت على تطوير صناعه دفاعيه
مستقله في السنوات الاخيره من بروكسيل
المعنى مراسل العربيه نور الدين الفريضي
اهلا بك معنا نور الدين اذا اجتماع
الوزراء الدفاع للدول الاوروبيه ماذا
نتوقع من هذه الاجتماعات
والمخرجات التي يمكن ايضا ان نتوقعها
اهلا فاطمه
مقاتلات الاف 16
وطيروها مساله الذخيره وانظمه الدفاع
الجوي والصواريخ التي تحتاجها اوكرانيا
حسب الدول الاوروبيه مطروحه الان على
طاوله وزراء الدفاع لدولي الاتحاد
الاوروبي فيما يتعلق
بمساله المقاتلات الاف سته عشر الدول
الاوروبيه او حتى دول حلف شمال الاطلسي
ككل ليست كل الدول تمتلك هذه الطائرات
تمتلكها مثلا بريطانيا هولندا
الدنمارك بلجيكا المانيا لها عدد قليل او
ربما
تريد المساعده ولكن من حيث تدريب الطيارين
بوريل قال صباح اليوم بان عمليه تدريب
الطيارين بدات فعلا لدى عدد من الدول
الاوروبيه وذلك يفتح الباب لتزويد
اوكرانيا بالمقاتلات مقاتلات اف 16
لكن المساله ربما الاكثر حيويه وعاجله
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا مسائل الذخيره وانظمه
الصواريخ انظمه الصواريخ التي تحتاجها
وهنا هناك مشكله منها ما يتعلق سياسيا بان
المجر تعطل الاجماع حول تمويل الاتحاد
الاوروبي مشترياتي اوكرانيا من الذخيره
واوكرانيا تنتظر مليون ذخيره هذا العام
لماذا المجر تقف هذا الموقف المعارض او
المعطل في على الطاوله الاوروبيه
يعني هم من يرى بان موقف المجرب ربما يكون
موقف وجيه بان تزويد الدول الاوروبيه
لاوكرانيا بالاسلحه وما الى ذلك قد فعلا
يعني يضر بامن هذه الدول ما المعلومات حول
ذلك او ما التفاصيل وكيف يتم معالجه هذه
المخاوف من قبل المجر
المجرى تبرر اعتراضها اليوم في مساله صفقه
المليون قذيفه او المليار التي سيقدموا
الاتحاد الاوروبي لتغطيه نفقات هذه
من الذخيره ان المجر ان كياب عفوا ان
اوكرانيا صنفت احد البنوك المجريه ضمن
قوائم سوداء او قوائم شركات التي تراها
اوكرانيا بان هذه الشركات تدعم روسيا
باعتبار انها تواصل التعامل مع السوق
الروسيه وعلى المتعاملين في سوق روسيا
وبالتالي واوكرانيا فعلا وضعت قائمه في
عدد كبير من الشركات الاوروبيه وغير
الاوروبيه ولكن نتحدث هنا عن الشركات
الاوروبيه من فرنسا بلجيكا اليونان قبرص
الى غير ذلك
اوكرانيا تطالب هذه الدول بالضغط على هذه
الشركات من اجل وقف التعامل معهم لكن هذه
المساله لم ليست مطروحه ولكن لم تحسم ولكن
في الحقيقه تعطل موقف
او تدعموا موقف المجر الان بالنسبه لي
سؤال حضرتك حول موقف المجر طبعا موقف
المجر يبدو يعني يعكس ربما شعور لدى الراي
العام من حول المخاوف من اتساع الحرب وان
مثل ما يقول البعض داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي
وخارج الاتحاد الاوروبي من مراسله دعم
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه هو في الحقيقه
الزيت على على الفتيل ولكن هذا الراي لا
يحظى بالاغلبيه وانما رغي اقل جدا على
طاوله الاجتماع لان المجر لها تحفظات على
مقاربه النزاع ككل بين روسيا
واوكرانيا لان هناك ابعاد داخل اوكرانيا
هي في الحقيقه حرب اوكرانيه روسيه ولكن هي
ايضا حرب بين الغربي وروسيا بين الناتو
وروسيا بين الولايات المتحده وروسيا من
هنا اوكرانيا كانت دائما المجر كان دائما
المتحفظه حتى ان يوما ما وربما حتى
العلاقه بين اورب ان ليست
مرضيه تماما حتى ان كلمه اخيره حتى ان
اوربان قال يوما عن
كوميدي اما هو قربان فهو رجل قانون تفضلي
جزيل الشكر لك من بروكسيل المراسل العربيه
نور الدين الفريضي
انباء عن هجوم اوكراني مضاد تقابله مزاعم
بان روسيا وتحديدا مجموعات فاجنر العسكريه
الخاصه تحاول تمرير اسلحه عبر دوله مالي
ولذلك لاستخدامها طبعا في اوكرانيا
المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
ماثيو ميلر كشف عن محاولات فاجنر اخفاء
المساعي حصولها على معدات عسكريه عبر دوله
ثالثه حيث اوضح ان هناك تسريبات تشير الى
ان فاجنر التي تمتلك قواعد في مالي تبتغي
تهريب شحنات اسلحه باستخدام وثائق مزوره
لهذه الصفقات التي يراقبونها عن كثب لكنهم
لم يؤكدوا تنفيذها بعد
بعد ان لجات روسيا لاسلحه جنوب افريقيا
لاحتداب معركه باخموت بحسب اتهامات غربيه
هذه المره تخطط روسيا لشحنها من مالي فمنذ
اكثر من عام سعد فاجنر الى توسيع شبكتها
في مالي وعلى ما يبدو ستدخلها خط الازمه
في اوكرانيا عن بعد مسؤول امريكي رجح ان
فاجنر تنقل معده عسكريه من مالي
لاستخدامها في حربها مع كييف ونقلا عن
معلومات استخباراتيه نشرتها
لم تنجح فاجنر في شراء العتاد من مالي
ولكن مساعيها نحو ذلك لا تتوقف الغامون
وطائرات مسيره ورادارات وانظمه بطاريه
مضاده كلها كانت ضمن طلبات فاجنر التي
زورت اوراق معاملاتها وفق سي ان ان ما
يعني ان روسيا لم تتجه لنقل الاسلحه من
تركيا وكوريا الشماليه فحسب وانما تستغل
دول العالم الثالث لتمرير شحناتها
العسكريه
نتحدث بعض الفاصل عن
نفي واشنطنيتها رفع العقوبات عن وزير
الدفاع الصيني
بدايه هشه للهدنه في السودان اطلاق نار
وتحليق للطائرات في الخرطوم واشتباكات في
ام درمان
اوكرانيا تؤكد انها لا تزال تسيطر على
مناطق في بخموت وتحذر من نقص الذخيره لبدء
الهجوم المضاد
بعد ضمان دعم اوغان اردوغان في اي مساومه
مع المرشح المنسحب وكليشجار اوغلو يؤكد لن
تخدع الشعب
محكمه اسلام اباد تمدد كفاله عمران خان ضد
الاعتقال في قضايا مكافحه ارهاب وفساد
احييكم من جديد اصيب عدد من الفلسطينيين
برصاص القوات الاسرائيليه غرب رام الله
بعد اقتحام القوات بلده نعلين واندلاع
اشتباكات وقامت القوات الاسرائيليه بتفجير
منزل منفذ عمليه زنغوف في تل ابيب في بلده
عليلين غرب رام الله وفي بلده قباطيه
مشاهدينا جنوب جنين اصيب اربعه فلسطينيين
بجروح خلال اشتباكات مسلحه ترافقت مع
اقتحام القوات الاسرائيليه للبلده
الى تركيا وبعد ان كسب الرئيس التركيه رجب
طيب اردوغان تاييد مرشح الرئاسه المنسحب
سنان اوغان في الجوله الثانيه من
الانتخابات التي تجري في 28 من مايو جاري
اكد اردوغان انه لم يساوم سنان اوغان
نافيا عقد اي مفاوضات معه او شروط مقابل
تاييد اوغان له بالحصول على منصب في
الحكومه الجديده وحول اللاجئين قال
اردوغان انقره تعمل على اعداد خارطه تعمل
على اعداد خارطه الطريق لعوده اللاجئين
السوريين الى بلادهم ومن جانبه علق مرشح
المعارضه كمال كليجدار اوغلو على تاييد
سنان لرجب طيب اردوغان وقال في تغريده له
على حسابه الرسمي قال لقد بات واضحا من
يقف بجانب تركيا ومن يقف بجانب بيعها
مضيفا ان هذا استفتاء ولا احد يستطيع ان
يخدع احد بعد الان
اخيرا حسم المرشح الخاسر في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه التركيه بجولتها الاولى سنان
اوغان قراره ودعم مرشح تحالف الشعب الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان
اطلبوا من ناخبين الذين صوتوا لنا في
الجوله الاولى التصويت للسيد اردوغان في
الجوله الثانيه
اوغان دعم مجددا الى ترحيل اللاجئين
معتبرا ان مشكلتهم تمثل قضيه امن قوميا
للبلاد ايضا انتقد حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي
الكردي وقال ان تحالف الامه المعارض لم
يقنعه موقف اوغان اشعل الجدل في التحالف
الذي يمثله وهو تحالف الاجداد فمنذ اعلان
نتائج الانتخابات البرلمانيه والرئاسيه
ظهر للعلن ان التحالف ليس على قلب رجل
واحد فيما يخص الجوله الثانيه حزب العداله
وهو حزب صغير داخل التحالف قرر المرشح
تحالف الامه كمال كالجدار اوغلو بينما
اعلن اوميت اوزداغ الذي يعرف بمواقفه التي
توصف بالعنصريه وهو رئيس حزب النصر الذي
ينتمي اليه اوغان اعلن ان قرار المرشح
الرئاسي بدعم اردوغان لا يعبر عن وجهه نظر
الحزب انما وجهه نظره الشخصيه لا يمكن ان
يكون هناك تصويت كامل من قبل كتله سنان
اوغان للرئيس اردوغان هذا موقف شخصي لسنان
اوغان وبالتالي تحالف الاجداد لا يمكن ان
يذهب كله للرئيس اردوغان لان ذلك سوف
يتعارض مع قيامهم ومباديهم التي اعلن عنها
والتي دخل مرشحهم منافسه لهم في
الانتخابات وحصل اوغان في الجوله الاولى
على 5.17 من الاصوات لكن نصف هذه الاصوات
جاءت من حزبي النصر والعداله اللذين فشلا
في دخول البرلمان بينما كانت بقيه الاصوات
من الكتله القوميه في تحالف طاوله
السداسيه الرافضين لترشيحك الجدار اوغلو
فقررت دعمه بعد انسحاب محرم انجي الذي صوت
شطر من انصاره ايضا لاوغان لا شك ان
اردوغان كسب في اعلان اوغندا دعمه له ورغم
تفتت تحالف الاجداد يحتاج اردوغان نسبه
مئويه بسيطه تضمن له الفوز بعكس منافسه
كالجدار اوغلو الذي يحتاج كامل الكتله
التصويتيه التي صوتت لاوغان في الجوله
الاولى وبراي كثيرين بات اردوغان اقرب
لحسم المعركه الانتخابيه في الرئاسه بعد
البرلمان لكن نسبه التصويت تبقى عاملا
اساسيا في يوم الحسم زيدان زنكلو العربيه
اسطنبول
معنى من اسطنبول الدكتور مهند حافظ اوغلو
الاكاديميه والباحث السياسي اهلا بك معنا
السيد مهند يعني اوغان خرج من الانتخابات
في الجوله الاولى بنسبه 5% او اكثر بقليل
بكسور من الجوله الاولى هذه الاصوات يعني
يعتقد بانها لن تذهب جميعها الى اردوغان
يعني ميرال اكسينار خرجت وقالت بانها لا
تعتقد بان جميع الاصوات ستذهب الى اردوغان
وكذلك التحليلات تشير بان هذه النسبه
ستقسم ما بين من لن يصوتوا يعني
بالانتخابات من سيصوت لاردغان ومن سيعطي
صوته ربما
تقييمك انت لدعم اوغان لاردوغان
جميع المشاهدين بالفعل هناك شروخات ليس
فقط في الاجداد كذلك في التحالف المعارضه
السداسيه او طاوله السداسيه كان لدى سنان
اوغان ملفاني اساسيان يناور به ما ليدخل
في عالم السياسه بشكل اقوى مما كان عليه
قبل الانتخابات الملف الاول هو ملف محاربه
الارهاب بحكم ان القوميين متعصبين جدا
لهذه المساله بشكل كبير وان الارهاب يجب
محاربته وعدم التوقف عنهم والملف الثاني
هو ملف اللاجئين ربما بعد دراسه المطوله
وصل سنان الى ترجيح ان ملف الارهاب هو
الاولى بالنسبه لمستقبل تركيا اما ملف
اللاجئين فبطريقتنا اخرى
الحكومه التركيه بالفعل قد بدات بالتعامل
مع اكثر من حكومه مؤسسيه مع النظام السوري
بشكل اساسي وبالتالي ربما نجد حدودا وهناك
عوده
لعشرات الالاف منهم شيئا وبالتالي هذا
الملف ليس مليحا وليس
بذات القيمه وذات الاهميه كمحاربه الارهاب
لذلك رجحت وطنيتهم ان يذهب الى الرئيس
اردوغان لانه يعلنها صراحه بان الارهاب
يجب محاربته ايا كان شكله وان محاوله
اقتطاع جزءا من تركيا واعطاء حكم ذاتي
لحسب الشعوب هذه الديمقراطيه كما وعدك
الحزب ومن خلف حزب العمال الكردستاني هذا
الامر رجح وطنيته سنان اوغن على ان يكون
لديهم
ذهاب نحو مصالح سواء حزبيه او شخصيه هذا
واضح من ان سنان اوغانك طبعا له طموحات
سياسيه قادمه وهذا سوف يزيد من تصيده في
داخل وقلب الشعب التركي لماذا لان رجح لان
الوطن على شخصيته وعدم مصالحه ومصالحه
تحالفه وبالتالي هناك بالفعل رؤيه جيده
بهذا
الدعم وان كانت يعني ما موقفت ليش دارها
الان في المحصله يعني راينا تصريحات من
الاشجار حول دعم اوغان ولكن ايضا راينا
بالامس يعني كثر يتخلون ربما عنك راينا
عده اعضاء من مجلس مؤسسي حزب المستقبل احد
عشر فرد منهم قدموا استقالتهم ويعني
الانباء تتحدث عن ربما يدعمون اردوغان
احمد امام اوغلو الذي يراس هذه
الحزب الداعم بشكل كبير ايضا هناك انباء
تتحدث انه ربما يعود الى احضان اردوغان
ويعود الى دعم اردوغان بالتالي كيف تقرا
هذه التحركات التي نراها هل هي لانهم
موقنون بفوز اردوغان في الجوله الثانيه
بالتالي يريدون ان يكون الى جانب الحزب
الفائز ام انهم بالفعل بداوا يؤمنون برؤيه
اردوغان وبمخططاته للدوله
نقطه في غايه الخطوره وغايه الاهميه
بالفعل ما بعد الثامن والعشرين من الشهر
الجاري في الحياه السياسيه التركيه
الداخليه لن يكون كما قبلها ربما نشهد
الكثير من الانعطافات قال علي بابا قبل
قليل انه ربما يتناقش مع الكتله النيابيه
ذات الغالبيه في البرلمان لاعاده تشكيل
دستور جديد للبلاد او تعديل بعض بنود من
الدستور الرئيس اردوغان كان قد قال انني
منفتح على كل الاحزاب وعلى كل اساسه لمن
يريد ان يتعاون معنا في مستقبل البلاد هذا
يعني ان هناك ما سوف يكون مختلفا عما كان
عليه قبل لا اظن ان احمد داوود اوغلو او
علي بابا جاد سوف ينسحبون من التكتل
السداسي ويذهبون الى رئيس اردوغان
ويدعمونه ولكن اللعب سوف تكون في البرلمان
التركي كون حزب المستقبل وحزب علي بابا
جان دخلوا البرلمان باربعين مقعدا او هذا
يعني لم يكن ليحلم به لولا التحالفهم في
الطاوله السداسيه مضره نافعه ضاره كما
تشتهر اوغلونا في عليه حزبي المستقبل
وعلي بابا جان وبمحصله اللعبه السياسيه
والحراك السياسي والشكل التكتلات السياسيه
المستقبليه في داخل التركي سوف تكون
مختلفه عما كانت عليه قبل صحيح ان
المعارضه سوف تبقى معارضه حسب المستقبل
سوف يبقى من الاحزاب المعرضه ولكن هناك
تنسيقا وهناك توافقا في بعض الجزئيات سوف
تكون في داخل البرلمان مع الاغلبيه التي
هي تحالف الجمهور اعني هنا حزب العداله
والتنميه الحاكم وحزب الحركه القوميه
وبالتالي سوف نشهد بالفعل في ايام القليل
القادمه والاسابيع القادمه الكثير من
التغيرات في خارطه التحالفات التعاونات
تساؤل الكبير سيد مهند ربما ما الموقف
السياسي وما المستقبل السياسي لكليجدار ما
ان خسر الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات شكرا
جزيلا لك من اسطنبول الدكتور مهند حافظ
اوغلو الاكاديمي والباحث السياسي
الى باكستان والتي قررت محكمه باكستانيه
تعنى بقضايا الارهاب قررت الموافقه على
طلب للفريق القانوني لرئيس الوزراء السابق
عمران خان بتمديد كفالات وقائيه ضد
الاعتقال في ثمان قضايا تتعلق باعمال شغب
وفوضى حتى تاريخ الثامن من يونيو المقبل
كما وافقت محكمه محاسبه على منحي زوجه
رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان كفاله
مؤقده مؤقته ضد الاعتقال على خلفيه قضيه
فساد حتى تاريخ 31 من مايو الجاري مقابل
ضمان مالي يناهز 7700 دولار امريكي الشرطه
الباكستانيه اعلنت مقتل سته اشخاص في هجوم
المسلح استهدف منشاه للنفط والغاز في
منطقه هانجو وقرب الحدود مع افغانستان
وذكرت الشرطه الباكستانيه ان الهجوم اسفر
عن مقتل اربعه من افراد الشرطه وفردي امن
متعاقدين واشارت الى ان تبادل اطلاق النار
استمر لساعاتي
فجر اليوم
الطيران التركي مشاهدينا استهدف منزلا في
قضاء سنجار في محافظه
نينوى شماليه العراق حيث ادت غاره جويه
الى تدميره بالكامل وتقول انقره غاراتها
الجويه في العراق تستهدف عناصر حزب العمال
الكردستاني والمصنف لديها جماعه ارهابيه
اعمار مختلفه في الناصريه جنوب العراق لم
تسلم من مرض الحمى النزيفيه ووضعت في
الحجر الطبي لتلقي العلاج وقد شهدت
المحافظه اجراءات صحيه مشدده لايقاف
ارتفاع الاصابات واهمها الارشادات التي
اعلنتها وزاره الصحه العراقيه للحد من
تفشي الوباء
زهراء الفتاه الجميله وحسين والحاج ابو
محمد بالرغم من اختلاف اعمارهم لكنهم
تشبثوا بالحياه بعد اصابتهم بمرض الحمى
النزفيه نقلوا ومعهم اخرون بعد الاصابه من
مناطق سكناهم الاهوار الى مستشفى العزل
الصحي وسط الناصريه جنوب العراق حيث تلقوا
العلاج بعضهم اكتسب الشفاء وسيخرج قريبا
وبعضهم الاخر تحت الاشراف المباشر وفي
العموم وصل عدد المصابين في هذه المحافظه
الى 35 حاله توفي منها سته وفقا لمصادر
طبيه
[موسيقى]
اخذنا الصبح وارجحنا الظهر والعصر هم نفس
الوضعيه
مع تخوف المواطنين من انتشار موجه جديده
للفيروس اعلنت خليه الازمه في الناصريه
تمديد حاله الانذار الصحي اجراءات هدفها
الحد من ارتفاع الاصابات تصاحبها حملات
تفتيش لمنع الجزاره العشوائيه الا في
الاماكن المرخصه القرار يعتبر ساري
المفعول حتى الثامن عشر من شهر يونيو
القادم وسيعاد النظر فيه بعد ذلك بين
القصابين في المناطق الريفيه والذين لديهم
احتكاك مباشر مع الحيوانات ومع اللحوم
لذلك نوصي
نوصي ونشدد الارشادات على ربات البيوت
وذلك باخذ الحيطه والحذر حين التعامل مع
مع اللحوم وتقطيع اللحوم وذلك بنفس الكفوف
وكذلك وضع اللحوم في الثلاجه وذلك لقتل
الفيروس
بعمليه التبريد
الوقايه واتباع النصائح الجديده التي بدات
تظهر على شكل ملصقات ومنها تبريد اللحوم
قبل الاكل لمده 24 ساعه ارشادات على
المواطنين اتباعها للحد من انتشار وباء
تعتبر الناصريه اكثر مدن العراق تضررا منه
من الناصريه شاكر عواد العربيه
الى الصراع الصيني الامريكي القديم الجديد
نفت الخارجيه الامريكيه نيتها دراسه رفع
العقوبات المفروضه على وزير الدفاع الصيني
ليشنك فون وقال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه
ان اداره بايدن لا تخطط لرفع العقوبات عن
وزير الدفاع الصيني او على الصين بشكل عام
وكانت الولايات المتحده استهدفت وزير
الدفاع الصيني بعقوبات في عام 2018 قبل ان
يتم تعيينه في منصبه الجديد في مارس
الماضي
نعود مشاهدينا لنذكر بتمديد كفاله رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان ضد الاعتقال في
قضايا ارهاب وفساد وحول ذلك ينضم الينا من
اسلام اباد عبد الرحمن المزيني مراسل
العربيه اهلا بك عبد الرحمن اذا هذه
الخطوه يعني ماذا تعني قانونيا وما
الاجراءات المتوقعه بعد هذه الخطوه
فاطمه العلي ابدا هنا من حيث اقف من امام
مكتب المحاسبه الوطني في سندباد احد
الفروع التابعه له حيث الان يخضع رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان
للاستجواب من قبل لجنه محققين على خلفيه
القضيه المرفوعه له بتهمه الفساد فيما
يعرف بقضيه وقف القادر والذي يتهم فيها
بالاستحواذ على اموال واراضي بقيمه 190
مليون جنيه استرليني
العمران خان وصل الى مقر مكتب المحاسبه
منذ نحو ساعتين من الان ولا يزال يخضع لي
الاستجواب من قبل المحققين اثناء مثوله
اليوم كان هناك اسئله من القضاه ومن
المحققين الذين سالوه عن سبب تغيبه عن
الجلسات السابقه تحدث عن انه يواجه 150
قضيه وبلاغ امام مختلف المحاكم الباكس كما
ان هناك تهديدات على حياته الى سيما هو
انه قد تعرض لمحاوله اغتيال قبل وصوله الى
مكتب المحاكمه او مكتب عفوا المحاسبه
الوطنيه عمران خان مثله امام محكمه تعنى
بقضايا الارهاب حيث قدم فريقه القانوني
طلبا للحصول او تمديد كفالات حصل عليها
وبالفعل مدد قاضي المحكمه الكفالات التي
حصل عليها الى الثامن من الشهر المقبل على
نفس السياق ايضا مساله زوجته بشرى بيبي
والمتهمه ايضا في قضيه توقف القادر الذي
اعتقل على اثرها قدم فريقها القانوني طلبا
للحصول على كفاله على خلفيه هذه القضيه
وبالفعل حصلت على كفاله حتى تاريخ 31 من
هذا الشهر اود الاشاره الى ان عمران خان
قبل وصوله الى السماد كان قد حث انصاره
كان يتوقع انه ربما يتم اعتقاله
اثناء وصوله امام مكتب المحاسبه الوطني
لكن ان ذلك لم يحصل حتى الان لكنه طالب
انصاره في حال تم اعتقاله بان يلتزموا
الهدوء والسلميه حتى لا يوفروا للسلطات
كما قال ذريعه لشن حمله اعتقالات في
صفوفهم عمران كان سبق وان اتهم السلطات
الباكستاني بانها شنت حملت حمله قمع
واعتقالات في صخور قالت نحو
7500 من انصاري في المقابل الحكومه
الباكستانيه اكدت انها سوف تشدد من
القوانين وسوف تحاكم المتهمين باعمال
الشغب والتخريبات حكوميه ومقر للجيش وفق
قانون الارهاب وايضا القانون العسكري عبد
الرحمن المزيني مراسلنا من اسلام اباد
شكرا جزيلا لك
بعثت الامطار التي هطلت غربي كندا
مشاهدينا املا لعناصر الاطفاء الذين
يكافحون حرائق مستعره في غابات البرتا حيث
قال مسؤولون في اداره مكافحه الحرائق ان
هذه الامطار تشكل نقطه تحول لاخماد السنه
اللهب التي التهمت اكثر من 945 الف هكتار
من الاراضي متفائلين بان هذه الامطار
ستعطي فرق الانقاذ فرصه لاحراز تقدم حقيقي
في السيطره على تلك النيران وبعد اسبوع من
هطول امطار غزيره في ايطاليا تسببت بفيضان
بفيضانات كبيره واودت بحياه 14 شخصا اعلنت
السلطات الايطاليه ان اكثر من 23 الف شخص
ما زالوا نازحين في شمال شرق ايطاليا حيث
انتقل معظم هؤلاء الى الاقامه عند اصدقاء
او اقارب في حين يقيم نحو 2600 في الفنادق
والمدارس ومراكز اخرى انشاتها السلطات
المحليه
في الختام نذكر دوما بالعناوين
بدايه هشه للهدنه في السودان اطلاق نار
وتحليق للطائرات في الخرطوم واشتباكات في
ام درمان
اوكرانيا تؤكد انها لا تزال تسيطر على
مناطق في بخموت وتحذر من نقص الذخيره لبدء
الهجوم المضاد
بعد ضمان دعم اوغان اردوغان ينفي اي
مساومه مع المرشح المنسحب وكليش دار اوغلو
يؤكد لن تخدع الشعب
محكمه اسلام اباد تمدد كفاله عمران خان ضد
الاعتقال في قضايا مكافحه ارهاب وفساد
في امان الله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات